prime minister boris johnson a key ally
announces that he is resigning
to the americans a key ally to the
germans a scandal noodle or glutton for
scandal whatever they called the prime
minister his spectacular demise has
seized the world's attention
from the start he was a different kind
of statesman for some a refreshing
change of character for others reason to
pity britain
for european allies the way he's pursued
brexit has been a constant cause of
frustration and anger the fact is that
the under boris johnson the british
government could not be relied upon
or i would say it could be relied upon
to be unreliable
he wants to critics too deferential to
donald trump who called him a british
version of himself you know this is does
everybody know he's going to be a
fantastic prime minister
but he maintained close relations with
his successor too on ukraine in
particular but viewed from the other
side of the atlantic his scandal-prone
time in office has ultimately not been
good for britain's place in the world
he's very intelligent he's extremely
engaging but as a political leader he's
also been deeply narcissistic and hasn't
been good for the united kingdom and so
even if the americans miss him we have
to recognize that this has been a bad
period for uk politics it has been beset
with scandal upon scandal upon scandal
boris johnson has been caught in lie
after lie after lie and they don't need
this
the russians gave a curt response
kremlin spokesman dmitry peskov saying
of the prime minister he dislikes us
very much we dislike him too
not so in ukraine though where he was
one of the first leaders to visit after
the war began he's seen as the most
dependable of allies in government and
on the street where they reacted with
regret to the news of his resignation we
are sad because of it we seen him come
here in kiev i think it's a big mistake
for ukraine because it's boris johnson
is our big friend
not surprisingly johnson's legacy on
ukraine is a part of his record one
favorite to succeed him wants to
preserve he has led from the front on
ukraine as he had on covid and obviously
brexit and i think that isn't lost on
many people but the whole of the
political system is supportive of what
we're doing in ukraine i don't expect
that to finish at all
most recently boris johnson seemed more
at ease on the world stage away from his
troubles back home
and like other leaders before him may
well be remembered more fondly abroad
than at home dominic waghorn sky news